Kathy hokel the Democrat Governor of New
York she is not happy with all the
illegal aliens who are making it to New
York the city may have dropped the ball
somewhat in dealing with this crisis
over a hundred thousand migrants
arriving in New York City since spring
of last year
no the mayor has had extraordinary
challenges he didn't invite all these
individuals in I think there was an
expectation that not so many would be
allowed to come to the border that
they'd relocate another state so no this
is nothing anyone could have anticipated
and it's been an enormous challenge you
literally asked for it when you have
described New York as a sanctuary state
that is the same thing as telling
illegal aliens come here you're not
welcome in other parts of the country
you are welcome here please come here